hey how you doing fighting this heaven
nice to meet you nice to meet you I'm
Elaine hallo Sinha I mean I'm sorry so
what do we have here so this is a cloned
cat get out of here
yes okay so far I have two questions
what's your question so since this is a
clone cat is there like a real cat that
looks like that one there is so there is
an original pet and that kind of still
alive and his owner decided he wanted to
clone him and now we have a cat that is
genetically identical to the original
cat okay let's see the case yeah okay do
they save the same stuff so that one's
not for you this have a heart he has a
heart he's a normal cat so he's a
special breed of cat called a Bengal cat
called a really big cat yeah he's a big
boy and he's only nine months old dad is
not gonna bomb that with a girl he's
really sweet he won't bite anybody or
anything okay so if you wanted to clone
trappy you would take him to your
veterinarian and your vet would take a
little small skin biopsy from his tummy
and then that sample comes to the Weiden
pets lab and we grow millions of cells
from the tissue and the cells contain
all of trapeese DNA
Wow and this owner has a four year old
cat that looks just like this looks
almost alike so some things that can be
a little bit different in a cloned
animal are the markings because a clone
is just an identical twin but the shape
of the face the shape of the ears the
eye color those are all things that are
genetically linked so we're going to be
very similar so trapeze super mint like
how would they act yeah temperament is
something that is genetically wait isn't
that amazing eyes so what's this cat's
name his name is Benji Benji yeah that's
Benji say what's up - Benji I have a
question so if you were to clone for
instance me boy I would like the person
think exactly like me and copy me or
have its own mind
so give me a give me a roundabout how
much would it cost to make a copy of
track how much so we're gonna start with
that preservation piece of storing the
DNA and that part is sixteen hundred
dollars just to get his skin off his
belt yes well your vets gonna charge you
a fee to take that skin but then we
charge sixteen hundred dollars to grow
these millions of cells from the skin
and to store that okay and there's an
annual storage fee that's one hundred
and fifty dollars a year okay now when
it comes time for cloning the dog
cloning is fifty thousand dollars hmm
cat cloning is twenty-five thousand so
this is a 25 thousand dollar category
$25,000 okay
goats and sheep and cows and pigs we
also clone horses are you some weed yep
horse cloning is 85 right what cloning
is hard it's not everyone can do it so
that's one reason the price is so high
yeah I'll go rub the cat y'all go do
that B I wanted to rub the cat nice okay
like a little pillow some sleep on
airplane so say you have a girl cat but
you clone it can you make it a boy or
decison so no okay come on so she can
finish education educating us in case
one of y'all get bad I just have another
one of you guys gonna replace you
anything you want to exhale oh yeah what
you want two eggs okay so if that cat
named like that first I request you to
tap out the question so if I go walks up
to your door please like how would they
ask
[Music]
and then you see I just walk away and
they were signing another joke for you
got anything you want to say straight
from the true family the chains family
over here well we've learned a process
about cloning so they in catch so if
this comes up in school you need to tell
your science teacher that it's going
down out here
okay I won't probably won't remember all
this stuff eNOS told us that's a car
don't do good